here is here is the puzzle right and if
you didn't already right
um because i didn't print it out for you
sorry that was a bit rude i would love
you to
write down the key parts of what you
think this puzzle
are because i'm going to refer to them
and you're going to need to refer to
them in
the proof that you create for this
because we can prove who's a liar and
who's a truth teller here
the first thing is i want you to think
back to that slide before which i'm
sorry i took down but
what is the basic building block of a
proof what are they
they are statements right
their statements you've been making all
kinds of statements the the question
itself the puzzle itself
has statements built into it now some of
them are really important and we need to
be able to refer to them right and i
don't want to keep on saying you know
when that guy said
i want to have you know when we say
triangle abc rather than
you know that triangle that's over there
in the left and it's the wider one not
the narrow one
so let's give something some names right
which do you think is the most important
statement
to refer to which one
tell me tell me what he says oh we're
all liars okay so
i'm gonna highlight that right and i'm
gonna say well this statement is
important i'm gonna have to refer to it
so i'm gonna give it a name
okay so i'm gonna call this guy here and
maybe you want to follow
suit i'm going to call it statement p
it's sort of customary to go p q r s and
so on okay
so that's good it's got a name right
statement p tell me the next statement
that matters
i've given you an easy example there are
actually only two things that are said
by anybody so
uh let's take that one just one of us is
a truth teller
and we'll give that name as well as i
said not particularly original i'm going
to call this
statement q now
we also have this um the the question
the puzzle it has a cast right it has
these people in it
and i don't want to have to keep on
saying first person second person
third person um anybody got time for
that so therefore i'm gonna
just name them right and i'll use some
letters um just so
i don't confuse statements and people um
i've got a couple of alphabets that i
can access and so do you
so i'm gonna call the first person alpha
the second person beta and i'll call the
third person
gamma okay so this is just so i can
refer them without having to use
long and awkward writing okay
right so now how do i use this
setup to create a proof well for
starters
i'm going to look at that first
statement and i'm going to consider or
like
you know suppose that the statement can
be either true or false right because
that's what all statements are it's one
or the other and there will be certain
implications from each one
right and that's actually a really
important word which i'm going to
introduce to you right
we're going to consider what flows if
the statement p is true
and if the statement p is false
but that id here and i'm gonna every
time i put in some new words i'm gonna
put in purple just so it highlights for
you
that logic is called an implication you
know if this statement is true
it implies and we use this arrow symbol
it implies other things okay
so uh for starters if the statement
is true p is true right we know that on
this island
who are the people who tell the truth
they're all true tellers right so if
this statement is true
the first implication i can see is that
alpha
is a truth teller
because only two truth tellers uh
tell truth so i'm actually going to
write that because that is a
substantiation for this statement so i'm
going to write
because
only truth tellers
say true statements i think i can fit it
just here
sorry my writing is going to get a
little messy
okay so like i said i'm going to sort of
highlight for you terminology
as i introduce it so we've got
implication you already know what
statements are
this thing in the brackets you're used
to doing this from deductive geometry
right
this is our reasoning or our
substantiation
okay fantastic but and i'm gonna ask you
guys to help me out here because i heard
this argument going around right
this is not the only implication if
statement p is true there's another
implication right and it causes a
problem
what's the other implication if
statement p is true
there are three liars right that all of
them are liars which includes
alpha right includes himself so the
other implication of this statement
being true is that alpha is a liar
and my substantiation for that is the
statement's content the statement itself
says something about itself so this is
my substantiation
because of the statement's content
now uh the final implication of putting
these two together oh sorry yeah did you
have a question or a thought
[Music]
would that be an implication or would
that be an assumption by saying
by that's a great question so what i've
done is
i have assumed i've assumed for a moment
that this is true
and then what i'm now doing is i'm
exploring the implications
of that statement being true and if if
this thing is not true in the first
place
then all of this kind of collapses which
in fact is exactly where i'm going
right so the implication of seeing
alpha is a true teller alpha's a liar we
would say and um you guys
use the word yourself right starts with
a c it's a contradiction and this is a
super important
uh piece of terminology you've used it
before but now we're going to formally
introduce it right
this is going to happen a fair bit it's
one of our main ways of proving
what we know because sometimes you
arrive at something which can't possibly
be true
okay so now uh we sort of
go further down and we say well if it
can't be true then the opposite must be
true right so
if p is false then what can we say about
alpha alpha's a
liar
and um not only can we say it's true
because we've gotten it from
up above but it's because parallel to
this logic over here you know how i said
before alpha's a true teller because
only truth tellers say true statements
i can say alpha's a lie down here
because look
only liars say false statements does
that make sense so that's actually my
substantiation
only liars say
false statements
okay so from here i can kind of use this
as my stepping stone i can form some
logical connections
into the rest of like beta and gamma and
try and work out what's going on with
them
so again going to introduce some new
language here right instead of saying p
is false i can actually say the opposite
of p is true let's say that again
if p is false then the opposite of p
is true now in the nature of truth in
mathematical logic we have a fancy name
for
the opposite we call it a negation right
um which we're familiar with this
language of negatives from just numbers
but in logic the negation of p is the
literal
opposite statement to p um and as you're
going to see in a second there's a
couple of different ways
to actually write the negation or the
opposite of something
so if i say that p means that all are
liars
the simplest way to say the negation of
p and we've got a symbol for this by the
way because
as we've already described we try and
introduce symbols so that we can say
stuff faster
so i'm just going to extend this down
here
we have a symbol for this and it's kind
of a weird symbol there's a couple of
different ones but the one i'm going to
use today looks like this
kind of looks like a step like you're
walking off of a step
so this i would read as the negation of
p
i'll zoom in so you can see it nice and
clear the negation of p
or not p that's the way that you might
read it okay
so the easiest way to say the negation
of p is to put a not
in front right and then just say the
statement so
if p is that all the liars then the
negation of p
is that not all are liars
okay uh now this is um
this is a helpful theme but it's not
super clear
so another way that we could say this is
we can say it not in terms of liars but
in terms of truth-tellers
if not all of them are liars how many
truth-tellers do there have to be
at least one there could be one or they
could be two or they could be three
so a way to capture all of those cases
is to say at least one of them
is a truth teller is that okay so i'm
going to write that at least one
is a truth teller
okay now um purple again because um a
bit more
notation and language for you see these
two things that you can see in green
here they're both
equal so what we would say is normally
we'd say are these
equal expressions but these are not like
numerical or algebraic expressions
they're logical
so we would say that these are called
equivalent statements
because one implies the other and it
goes in both directions
so these are equivalent statements
[Applause]
um now you know how you can see above
i've got these arrows that say
implies right implication so if two
statements
imply each other what symbol do you
think they would use to indicate
that it goes in both directions
it's a yeah it's it's an arrow that is
two-sided
right so equivalent statements they
imply
one another so the arrow goes one way
and also simultaneously goes
the other way okay now just before i
jump off of here and look at the next
statement
i also want to highlight these two words
or phrases
actually these two here so all
or at least one they tell you something
about how many things are true
right so we have a name for this a bit
of a fancy word
we call these quantifiers
as in quantity right so these are
statements of size
or number okay how many things are true
all of them
some of them at least one at least two
and these are all quantifiers okay
all right so this is really good we've
got um
some logic that's established like i
know some of you were kind of stumbling
over this and you didn't know how to
articulate
how you knew that the first person was a
liar apple's lie but this is
how we construct a proof for it okay
let's have a look at the next statement
shall we
that statement q okay so what i'm going
to do is think about
like i did for statement p what happens
if they're true
what happens if they're false okay i'm
going to truncate some logic here
because i think you're following already
if q is true what can we say about this
second person beta
if their statement's true yeah that's
true
right um and we know already the
substantiation for that it's the same as
up above
so b would have to be a true teller
because only true tellers tell truth
but that has an implication right
have a think about this carefully with
me
what is the content and you've got it um
i actually
have i got it up above i do have it up
above right what is the content
of beta's statement he says
just one of us is a truth teller so
if he is or she is a truth teller then
what can we conclude in addition to the
fact that they are a truth out
that a and c are yeah very good
right so this second person beta is the
only
truth teller right um or that alpha and
gamma are not so i'm going to write it
like so beta is the only truth teller
i'm just going to highlight that because
that's the difference here
and where i get that from is from the
content
of statement q okay now at the moment
on this logic i've just supposed that
it's true i don't actually know it
for a fact so i'm going to have a look
at this other branch and see what
happens
what if statement q is false what can we
say about beta
if their statement's false yep they're a
liar
beta is a liar
but this implies um some interesting
things here right
if they are a liar now have a look at
the content
of their statement the the content was
that there's only one
truth-teller right but we're now
supposing that that's not true
so how many truth tellers could there be
we know there can't be one because we've
just assumed it's false so what are the
other options there's only three
zero or two or three
right now i'm going to write all of
those cases because each one
has an implication so if there can't be
one true teller there's either zero true
tellers
or two true tellers or three
truth-tellers now
each of these possibilities has a
problem with it
and maybe if you have a look up above at
my logic here
and you think about the way you
explained to the person you were sitting
next to
why you actually made a conclusion about
this i need to refer to some of the
statements that i need to be true up
above okay
so to do that i need to again give some
name to things okay
so let's have a look at
let's have a look at this one up here
alpha
is a liar we know that to be true
right we've gone through some logic so
because i know that to be true i'm going
to give this statement another name i've
already used p and q so i'm going to
call that one statement r
okay now why is statement r
relevant if uh
if alpha is a liar and
beta is also a liar right
how many liars are there there are two
right
so i can say wait a second there's a
contradiction
here because i can say off of this
statement here
this can't possibly be true it
contradicts
r right
because they said alpha's a liar um
and that means that they can't possibly
be two at the same time
right uh what about
statement uh this statement here
statement three
this contradicts something too why can't
there be three truth-tellers
have a think about what we already know
vran
what is it the negation of statement huh
okay so we're looking up here right
statement p was that all the liars
but we know that's actually not true we
know that the negation of p is true
so i'm going to highlight that in orange
as well
this is true here i don't need to give
it another name because it already has
a name not p so therefore i can say oh
there's a contradiction here
[Applause]
with not p
and that's actually the same for the
last case right see this one
do you see that's also contradicted
think about this right
there can't be zero truth tellers
because we know there has to be
at least one truth teller do you
remember that i wrote it up in green
before so this also
contradicts
not p so you see every possible thing
that flows out of q being false they all
lead to contradictions so
what does that mean can q still be false
no
q can't be false because every single
branch that comes out of it
is a contradiction so therefore i know
in fact
that this statement up here must be true
you're following i sort of exclude
things um that can't be
the case and i know that's a bit weird
we're used to making mathematical proofs
where everything is true
but actually we have to wrestle with the
things that are false as well otherwise
we can't get to the bottom of things
okay are you ready to make a conclusion
right who's telling the truth
only only beta is telling the truth
oops
and uh as we said before i think calvin
mentioned it right
that means alpha and gamma they have to
be
liars because beta was telling the truth
when he said there's only one true
teller
he's the only one she's the only one
whoever they are so therefore the others
are liars so i know that was a weird
interesting way to go about
it we had to introduce a whole bunch of
new language and notation to do it
but are you now convinced right there's
no more yeah but
i heard some of you say it doesn't make
sense or it has to be this
but you didn't have the logic underneath
it that have been proven okay